mein Name ist Florian tomaschke und
jetzt freue mich dass ich hier
unser Konzept vorstellen darf
es geht eben um das Thema future
workskills Zeit und und
lernoptimale Inhalte sage mal es passt
ganz gut ich habe mir das vorerst im
Vortrag vom Adam davon notiert die
Nachteile der Vorlesungen also
unterschiedliches Vorwissen relativ viel
Wissen in kurzer Zeit das waren so Dinge
die uns umgetrieben haben
an der Hochschule und daraus haben uns
überlegt irgendwas muss man doch machen
und dann kam er Projekt indem Sie die
Möglichkeit gab sowas umzusetzen
und dann haben wir das getan und das
würde eben gern vorstellen der Titel ist
äh future workskills im Bachelorstudium
selbst Einheiten und präsenzinhalte
lernen optimal und Zeit orientiert
kombiniert ich habe jetzt darüber noch
mal geschrieben in orange die ist Story
immer überlegt oder nicht aber bei uns
heißt es eben die Story und ich werde
nicht drum kann man ganz oft dieses
Story zu erwähnen und deswegen muss ich
kurz erklären was es geht also wie heißt
Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen das ist die
Fakultät und der ich tätig bin dann in
die haben das entwickelt haben und
Stories einfach die Geschichte die man
erzählen wollen und was diese Story ist
würde jetzt einfach mal versuchen
ich würde mal starten kurz zu erklären
was war die Idee wer sang wir wer also
das eigentlich ausgedacht dann oben über
die kurz darauf eingehen oder wie zu
einsteigen was ist da ziehen und was an
die Ziele was das Inhalt von dem ganzen
und ganz wichtig noch mal weil es ja der
Fokus ist und das hast Du unser Gedanke
war wie hängt es mit dem Thema Zeit
zusammen also wie was bringt mir das zum
Thema Zeit und dann am Ende habe ich nur
kurzes Beispiel dabei das ist ganz
jugendlich noch ein bisschen deutlicher
und greifbarer wird
ich bringe mal in die erste und das
erste die hier rein quasi wir sagen mal
irgendwann gestartet eben genau mit dem
Hintergrund dass man so wie immer diese
Leere bei uns verbessern wie immer die
wird für die Zukunft machen
ja nächsten habe ich nächste Level
bringen
und
da waren so Gedanken ja wie immer das
ganze greifbar machen
wie schaffen irgendwelche Zusammenhänge
zwischen den Inhalte herzustellen wie
wird das für die Studierenden
interessanter
und vor allem wenn man sowas machen war
immer der Gedanke wie schaffen wir es
auch in diesem ohnehin durchgetakteten
bachelor-alltag
die Studierenden mitzunehmen und ihnen
nicht irgendwie nur mehr aufzuhalten
sondern zu sagen okay das was wir jetzt
uns da ausdenken das was wir da machen
also mit dem ganzen was wir eben das
interessante und Lehrern machen wollten
wie schaffen wir das dass es für euch
spannend ist und umsetzbar ist und
vielleicht auch
zur besseren Lehre beiträgt und Zeit
spart
es gab erste Ideen erste Konzepte
Abschlussarbeiten damit beschäftigt
haben und dann sammeln irgendwie in die
Richtung gehen okay es war doch ganz
nett wenn man durch die Geschichte haben
die wir über dieses wie Studium erzählen
könnten also wir haben ein festes
Produkt Unternehmen dass sich wieder
runterfahren durch das ganze Studium
zieht und dann
anhand dessen die Lehrinhalte abbildet
jetzt haben wir dann eben versucht mit
dieser wie Story und für die
Studierenden Lehrenden Mehrwert schaffen
und
warum haben wir das eigentlich gemacht
ja wir sind wir eigentlich warum jetzt
bei uns und was bringt uns das
wie ich Studium jetzt ich denke
eigentlich jede sie ist jemand vor allem
bei uns in Rosenheim ist geprägt dass
man da sehr viel aus sehr
unterschiedlichen Bereichen
lernt also der Wirtschaftsingenieur der
nimmt Inhalte aus der Technik mit der
nimmt aber Inhalte vom Betriebswirt aus
der Wirtschaft mit und bringt es
irgendwo zusammen und so hat
integrations
Themen also darüber hinaus über diese
wirtschaftliche Themen Themen wie sage
ich mal selbst Management
Führungskompetenzen
Sprachen und so weiter dann relativ
breiten Strauß anhalten
wichtig ist außer gemeint das Thema
ganzheitliches Denken und Vernetzung und
eben diese einzelnen Inhalte muss man
irgendwie zusammen bringen und dafür ist
so gemein da das ist diese Idee
entstanden und das wo man damit schaffen
vielleicht kurz was jetzt die meisten
werden oder die dir vielleicht aus
München sein werden nur wissen wo
Rosenheim ist die ein bisschen weiter
weg sagen ja wir sind lügen aber nur
Zuge halbe Stunde von München Richtung
Südosten in der Nähe vom Chiemsee
unser Hochschule hat
neben dem Haupt schon in Rosenheim nur
ein paar außenstandorte wie zum Beispiel
Burghausen was um das Thema Chemie geht
das Chemie Eltern in Deutschland wenn
man standardmäßig mit
dem Schwerpunkt Pflege beschäftigt genau
wir sitzen aber als wie in Rosenheim
haben drei Studiengänge dann
wahrscheinlich jetzt mit der Uni
verglichen eher klein an der Hochschule
ist gar nicht so klein am 15 Professoren
11 Mitarbeiter und das ist wichtig so um
die 400 Studierenden regelmäßig in
diesen drei Studiengängen
genau und eben wichtig bei uns ist es
ganzheitliche denken
da Wirtschaftsingenieur der ist in einem
relativ breit gefächerten Bereich dann
unterwegs dann noch
daraus ist das Ganze entsteht dieses
solche
aus diesem raus immer raus ist dann ein
Konzept entstanden
bis jetzt gerne vorstellen wird und zwar
ich starte einfach mit die Ziele so kurz
was zum Aufbau was haben die Inhalte und
wird es ganz kurz erklären
ich springe hier mal rein
genau es ging uns quasi darum dass man
sagt wie können wir die Inhalte von wie
Studium irgendwie verknüpfen also wie
kann man das ganze greifbar machen und
dazu haben wir uns dieses Produkt
E-Scooter überlegt also unser
beispielprodukt das ganze Studium zieht
wir roter Faden ist eben dieser
E-Scooter und dazu gibt es letztendliche
Musterunternehmen also Romy das haben
Rosenheimer mobility Werke genannt und
dieses Musterunternehmen ist an den
einzelnen Modulen von wie Studium
orientiert die habe ich auf der nächsten
Folie dann gleich mit dabei und werde
noch mal erklären wie das wie das rote
Faden funktioniert
weiterhin war es wichtig dass man so
okay wie kann man denn dieses Wissen
problembasiert in die Anwendung bringen
also wie immer quasi weg von dieser
klassischen Vorlesung und übungsstruktur
wie es üblich waren da Hochschule
bisschen dahin gehen wir dass die
Studierenden die Möglichkeit haben
erlerntes Wissen das vielleicht dann aus
der Vorlesung kommt dann einzusetzen
oder oder so eine anzuwenden und dazu
haben uns überlegt wenn dieser E-Scooter
in einzelnen Modulen als Beispiel
vorkommt und diese Module ein bisschen
so aufgebaut sein dass sie Unternehmen
widerspiegeln könnten wir ja wirklich
reale Problemstellungen aus
Wirtschaftsunternehmen damit einbauen
also das war's dann zum Beispiel die
machen sie irgendwie in der Fertigung
Gedanken wie konnten zur E-Scooter
gebaut werden sondern hergestellt werden
und dieses Vorwissen haben Sie entweder
aus der Vorlesung aus selbsteinheiten
dass Sie wissen okay was gibt's denn für
unterschiedliche Fertigungsverfahren
oder Fertigungsmöglichkeiten
gleichzeitig schafft man natürlich wenn
das was wir davor wenig bis gar nicht
hatten Zusammenhänge zwischen Inhalten
und Modulen also es werden solche
entstehen Schnittstellen durch diesen
roten Faden durch diese Unternehmen
Story ähm dann gesagt ja wieso brauche
ich eigentlich im ersten Semester das
Modul Marketing
man merkt okay das ist ja dann richtig
für irgendein anderes Modul ist dann
später der Stelle kennt
zusätzlich war der Gedanke nun ja wie
kommen neben dem dass man skreifbarer
und verständlicher vermittelt hat die
Inhalte Nummer die Stärken und Schwächen
der Studierenden fördern
und da haben wir nochmal das habe ich
auch eine Folie jetzt gerne dabei so
Charaktere geschaffen die
unterschiedliche Profile abbilden mit
denen Sie dann die Studierenden
letztendlich identifizieren können
der Aufbau und die Idee waren Folgen
auf der rechten Seite wir haben
verschiedene profilierungsblöcke die
sich an verschiedenen future
works-skills orientieren also das ist
nichts fest relativ lose aber die
studieren können entscheiden okay mich
interessieren werden im Studium jetzt
gerade ganz spezielle Themen Energie und
Nachhaltigkeit oder mir ist
Digitalisierung wichtig und diesen
profilierungsblöcken sind einzelne
future works Kills zugeordnet die man
dann in diesem Modulen erwerben können
und je nach Interesse wählt man diese
Module dann dann entlang diesen
probieren aus und
es gibt
Grundmodule die muss natürlich jeder
absolvieren und dann gibt's eben
Wahlmodule die man dann eben auswählen
konnte und diesen übergeordneten ist
eben immer dieses wie Produkt und je
nachdem wo ich mich dann begebe
scheinbar eben diesen Scooter vielleicht
noch mal aus
nachhaltigkeitspunkten an
oder
ich schaue okay wie werden diese
technisch wie ist was ist da steckt auf
der Technik drin
so gemein Richtung
it natürlich begrenzt aber wie kann man
sowas digitalisieren was was steckt denn
diese Richtung mit drinnen und der rote
Faden die nur eingezeichnet habe deshalb
dann die verknüpften Module in unserem
Studium die immer diese Geschichte von
diesen E-Scooter von dieser Firma weiter
treiben
was in Arbeit ist oder was das Kind
immer mit dabei ganz wesentliche
Aspektes um das Thema Zeit sollte man
normal
reinzubringen ist zwar
semesterübergreifendes Booklet in dem
sich dann diese Ergebnisse oder Inhalte
aus dem Modulen wiederfinden und einen
anderen Stellen dann gezielt sowohl von
die Studierenden abgerufen werden können
beispielhaft habe ich mal auf der Folie
paar so Module drauf die bereits
miteinander verknüpft sein
wenn man jetzt sagt okay
ich habe jetzt vielleicht irgendwie
das Modul Fertigungsverfahren okay wie
hängt es denn mit dem Modul Buchführung
zusammen wieso brauche ich denn das
eigentlich ja weil ich muss ja wissen
okay was kostet mich dieser ist gut und
da gut dann wie das Thema Marketing rein
wie bringen Kunden irgendwo rüber
was diese E-Scooter kostet was der
überhaupt Kosten und so dann eben diese
ganzen Module wie so Puzzle Steine
mittlerweile miteinander verknüpft
und ich hatte es erwähnt gehabt wir
haben
einfach mal so Charaktere geschaffen
die sie Charaktere dienen dazu die
durchlaufen eigentlich diese Geschichte
also das haben fiktive Studierende mit
verschiedenen Stärken und Schwächen die
einfach mit seiner Profil geschrieben
sein wo dann die Studierenden also die
real Studierenden gezielt Song Kinder ja
ich identifiziere mich hier mit dem Tom
bei Marketing und Vertrieb ist das was
mir Spaß macht das was ich eigentlich
kann und dann muss Übungsgruppen eben
dieser Tom übernimmt im Park oder er
sagt ganz
bewusst ja aber jetzt irgendwie
Entwicklung Konstruktion ist nicht meins
in der Schule so schwer getan vielleicht
mit Mathe und so weiter ja dann gehe ich
jetzt ganz speziell in diesem
charakterien übernehmen in eine
Übungsgruppe diesen diesen basteln
so durchlaufen die eben diese diese
Geschichte vom ersten bis zum 7 Semester
und können individuell für sich eine
Stärken und Schwächen ausbauen und sich
eben nur mal sagen
meine
interessenierungsmodule wählen
das ganze ist 2018 mit ersten Ideen
gestartet im ersten Konzepten wir haben
dann während Corona begonnen das in
ersten Modulen einzusetzen das war dann
mehr oder weniger so dass in der
Vorlesung plötzlich dieser E-Scooter als
produktbeispiel aufgetaucht ist jetzt
aber nur konkrete Verknüpfung von
Inhalten stattgefunden hat
letztes Wintersemester also
die sagen es dann ein Jahr mit dabei
sammeln da mit dem ersten Durchlauf
gestartet also die haben jetzt wirklich
also die kann man jetzt Semester die
haben jetzt wirklich von Anfang an diese
wie Story diesen E-Scooter diese Firma
als Beispiel mitgenommen und haben in
ihrem Module immer diese Inhalte gehabt
haben am Anfangs Workshop gehabt wenn es
dann wenn Workshop kommen der ist quasi
weiter begleitet und ähm jemand da jetzt
das ganze mit da steht es dann für uns
immer Evolution an wo man sagen okay
wie kommt denn das an wo müssen wir uns
verändern oder was verändern wie geht's
weiter und die nächsten jetzt für den
Wintersemester kommen starten auch
wieder mit diesem Thema
wie hängt jetzt aber oder für uns war
wichtig irgendwie also von Anfang an zu
sagen okay ist der von mir Aufwand sei
es muss also immer neben diesen ganzen
Optimierung der Lehre des Thema Zeit mit
rein das spielt für unsere Rolle ja und
wie steckt es damit drin also wir haben
uns gedacht durch dieses
Grundlagenwissen das ja vorhanden ist
doch dieses
müssen zu diesem E-Scooter zu diesem
Muster Unternehmen zu diesem Inhalten
diesen Booklet vorhanden sein die sind
einfach da bei den Studierenden oder
arbeiten wir müssen uns jedes Mal und
irgendein neues Übungsbeispiel ein
denken oder in der Vorlesung irgendeine
nice Beispiel aufbauen wir haben diesen
E-Scooter wir haben diese Daten doch
also das ganze ist vorhanden wir können
eigentlich egal in welcher Nation wir
sitzen da wieder einsteigen
dann haben wir ganz stark das Thema
selbst einen halten
oder für uns bedeutet das
wir haben vorgeschaltet zu den
Modulen also das ist ein Teil also
dieser Teil der davor für irgendwie
Vorlesungszeiten vorgesehen war es wird
für selbsteinheiten vorgesehen wo eben
die Studierenden
beliebiges
Tempo das Ganze also die die notwendigen
Inhalte vorbereiten und sich die
notwendigen Vorkenntnisse aneignen und
dann besteht jetzt runter im
präsenzeinheiten wie das ganze Problem
was wird anzuwenden
durch diese
semesterübergreifende Nutzung und somit
das gezielte ja die dieses Vorwissen ist
vorhanden ist
dann natürlich alle diese
präsenzeinheiten diese selbsteinheiten
wesentlich
ja Zeit optimal abzuarbeiten was dazu
kommt es bei uns wir haben sehr viele
die bereits Ausbildung absolviert haben
das bedeutet wenn wir in der Module wie
zum Beispiel Betriebswirtschaft
einsteigen dann gibt's da welche die
kennen diese Inhalte weil die hatten die
in der Ausbildung Grundstudium und dann
können Sie natürlich vielleicht sogar
selbsteinheit überspringen wie jemand
der mit dem technischen Hintergrund zu
uns kommt noch nie was davon
die die die Schwerpunkte auf deswegen
was er irgendwie gerade benötigt
jetzt habe ich noch mal versucht das
Ganze ein Beispiel abzubilden also wir
setzen das ganze schon in in 20 Modulen
ein aktiv also wir haben es in 20
Minuten geplant und setzen es in 14
Modulen aktiv ein da ist es schon
gestartet es liegt daran dass diese
anderen sechs Module einfach Module der
höheren Semester sein und diese erste
Urlaub nicht angekommen aber es geht
immer weiter da habe jetzt neue unseren
E-Scooter mitgebracht das der schaut so
aus der ist bei uns vorhanden ist
zerlegtes Produkt und jeder Studierende
die Teile holen die er gerade braucht
und in die Vorlesung in die Übung in die
selbsteinheit mitnehmen er ist fahrbares
Produkt also zusammengebaut
wenn man irgendwas nutzen möchte
während dem studiumswert diesen
Durchlauf bauen die Studierenden diesen
E-Scooter auch nochmal selbst also wir
fertigen den soweit möglich ist nur bei
uns an die einzelnen in die einzelnen
Labore selbst dass sie das Miterleben
was gehört eigentlich dazu es war
Produkt irgendwann fertig zu stellen in
unserem Unternehmen zu arbeiten
und begleiten das Ganze eben in unserem
Onlinekurs wo dann für Studierende und
Dozierende die ganzen Inhalte hinterlegt
sein diese dann in den einzelnen
Semestern benötigen da gibt es Inhalte
die sagen letztendlich für alle gleich
sind Durchlauf irgendwo gleich und dann
gibt es Inhalte die werden
semesterspezifisch in den Vorlesungen
erarbeitet
vielleicht an der Stelle ist wirklich so
sagen den produzierst natürlich frei wie
ob sie da das sage mal anwenden das tun
bei uns ist eigentlich alle aber tief
immer nur einsteigt der steht eben frei
der eine sagt er nimmt vielleicht
wirklich nur als neues Beispiel hier
orientiert seine Inhalte daran wirklich
ganz konkret ganz praktisch in dieses
Unternehmen ein und er hätte zahlen und
gibt die dann leider braucht
zum Abschluss habe ich noch mal
Übungsbeispiel aus dem vierten
Studiensemester mitgebracht das jetzt so
schon in der Anwendung ist
und da geht es darum an Arbeitsplan für
erteilt zu erstellen also E-Scooter Teil
zu erstellen das ist dann in der
Fertigung tatsächlich hergestellt werden
kann
unter Einstieg ist eben mit unseren
Charakteren in dem Fall diese Roxana der
Tom und diese Isabel diese Themen
brauchen und jetzt kann sie eben die
Studierendengruppe aussuchen diese
kleinen Gruppen aussuchen
in welche
Rolle schlüpfe ich den jetzt was möchte
ich jetzt doch ganz konkret
beitragen das Vorwissen zu dieser
eigentlichen Arbeitsplan des Kunden
Studierenden schon mal für sich sich
angeschaut haben wie schaut zur Arbeit
da in der Theorie aus also wie wäre der
aufgebaut
und Nachteile von unserem Arbeitsplan
dass er sich jeder so gemein zu Hause
oder in der Gruppe davor schon mal
angeschaut
früher wäre es so gewesen jetzt
vielleicht auch schon Übungen im
zusammenarbeitsplan da war dann dieser
dieses Thema Arbeitsblatt in der
Vorlesung zuvor behandelt worden jeder
hat das anhören müssen so wie gesagt von
jeder für sich entscheiden brauche ich
das Wissen weiß ich das wie viel
intensiv
es geht dann weiter eben dass man sagt
okay jetzt dazu diese Arbeitsplan
erstellen wenn es jetzt einzelne
Übungsaufgaben Schritte wichtig man
sieht zum Beispiel runden es geht um CAD
Zeichnungen die wir hier brauchen ist es
dann Zeichnungen wo dieses Bauteil weil
sie ausgezeichnet wurde und diese CAD
Zeichnung fehlt jetzt aber nicht vom
Himmel sondern die haben diese drei
vielleicht im Vorfeld im Semester davor
schon selbst gezeichnet und in einem
Booklet abgelegt
sie wissen wie entsteht zu erzählen sie
wissen was hat man dafür Probleme sie
kennen das gleiche Arbeitszeiten
übernehmen so ist das ganze wesentlich
Praxis mehr und ich denke wir denken für
die Studierenden interessante und
greifbarer
oder hier oben genauso geht es um
Stücklisten diese Stückliste sein im
Vorfeld schon selbstständig studieren
erstellt wurden indem sie diesen
E-Scooter teilweise zerlegt haben die
Teile genommen haben und einfach mit
geschaut haben
zusätzlich auf die nächsten Folien habe
ich einfach nur mit das mitgebracht sie
können natürlich auch hier um das zu
vereinfachen dazu beschleunigen was
jetzt zu komplex nochmal so ein
Stückliste als Beispiel mit also dass
Sie wissen okay an was müssen wir uns
jetzt erinnern oder Sie können normaler
Zeichnung mit wie muss jetzt die
Zeichnung ausschauen oder was war denn
das eigene so muss man die natürlich
irgendwo nur mitnehmen aber das
Vorwissen zu seiner Zeichnung ist
vorhanden sie haben das selber schon mal
gemacht kannten wenn sie möchten Ihr
eigene Zeichnung abrufen
das ganze Ende dann dass man sagt okay
ähm wie was nehmen raus mit was ist denn
wichtig für unser nächstes Modul was
müssen wir vielleicht irgendwie eine
speichern
wie geht's dann weiter also wer jetzt
einfach mal beispielhaft zur Übung
abgebildet
ja ich hoffe ich habe
in der kurzen Zeit jetzt einfach mal ich
glaube die Zeit ist am Ende oder ja
rüber braucht was wir uns gedacht haben
was zu unserer Idee war dahinter
am Ausprobieren ich sagte wir wollen das
ganze evaluieren
ich möchte mich nur bedanken dass ich da
vorstellen darf und äh freue mich jetzt
hat drauf wenn es irgendwelche Fragen
gibt oder vielleicht irgendwelche
kritischen Punkte wenn man sagt sehe ich
anders oder oder meine Erfahrung ist
anders
ja genau